one of the Internet's principal hobbies
is remembering the 90s which I totally
get
I can see the appeal of kicking back
with some dunkaroos and classic episodes
of Rugrats but just because something
was popular in the 90s doesn't mean we
should revive it case in point a very
troubling BuzzFeed article suggesting
that frosted tips are making a comeback
of new way how long before we're
chugging Zima and doing it all for the
nookie comedians if for some reason you
want to Don the devil spikes what's
something you would tell the barber to
get this look
Justin make me look like I just got
kicked out of o town all right boys
Frogger just make me look like a
stretched-out Guy Fieri
all right Paul the goatee okay please
make me look like a poisonous Australian
fruit all right boys yeah very good